everybody's got a question
hey Twitter question Jacqueline I'm a
double to know my favorite TV show is
well I don't have cable but do have a TV
and it's connected to my laptop of which
I watch Hulu and iTunes I made a list of
some of my favorite shows just to make
sure I didn't leave any outs
we've got a house damages fantasy
factory Mad Men Gossip Girl glossed
Arrested Development I know it's been
long gone but it's a great show man vs.
wild dollhouse fringe 30 rock real-world
Brooklyn
there any of the shows I should be
watching cuz if there is let me know
gymnast girl bananas and cheese - I like
them together I've actually never tried
that
hey Justine what's your favorite part of
being famous on the Internet well the
best part about being famous online is
any time I go to get a coffee I never
have to pay for it cuz they always know
who I am
picture Starbucks can I take your order
please
yeah double tall nonfat vanilla latte
that'll be 355 don't you know who I am
yes you're a customer I'll keep my money
and I guess the best part about being
famous online is that nobody in the real
world has any idea who you are that was
me playing the drums and that brings us
to ask IJ number seven coming to a close
now if you guys have made a response
video before and I haven't answered your
question add it again add your response
video again and as always leave the
comments ask the questions on Twitter